un escalofriante informe elaborado por
dos grupos juntos contra la pena de
muerte e Irán Human Rights evidencia Un
aumento del 75% de las ejecuciones en
Irán el año pasado sobre todo desde que
comenzaron las protestas a Escala
Nacional en septiembre tras la muerte de
Max a mini bajo custodia policial los
autores del informe afirman que Teherán
está recurriendo a la pena capital para
sofocar la revuelta la pena de muerte se
utiliza para intimidar a la población
para demostrarle que el gobierno tiene
el control sobre su vida o su muerte
amnistía internacional afirma que este
año las autoridades iraníes han
ejecutado al menos a 94 personas solo en
enero y febrero las minorías étnicas
representan una proporción alarmante el
30% pertenecen a los grupos kurdo y
balucci otros grupos son los alguacies y
los aseríes
estas minorías parte del Mosaico
multiétnico de Irán tienen
reivindicaciones políticas algunos
quieren la independencia o más autonomía
y la única forma de silenciarlas es la
pena de muerte
Irán es el segundo país del mundo
después de china con mayor número de
ejecuciones las mujeres están sobre
representadas en el corredor de la
muerte y los menores no están exentos el
nuevo informe denuncia juicios injustos
que a veces duran solo semanas con
presos a menudo obligados bajo tortura a
confesar